estamos hablando del sistema inmunitario
adaptativo o específico y ya hemos visto
que hay un par de actores primero tienes
la respuesta moral esta respuesta alude
a las cosas que están flotando por los
fluidos del cuerpo y no necesariamente a
las cosas que se han filtrado en las
células del cuerpo y por otra parte
tenemos la respuesta de inmunidad
celular en la respuesta moral y hablamos
de la respuesta moral específica es
donde tenemos las células de los
linfocitos b en su punto más activo
básicamente lo que éstas hacen vamos a
dibujar una célula ve por aquí es que
tenemos nuestro anticuerpo muy
específico específico para esta célula
pero ojo no para las células ve en
general y si entre las miles de millones
de células p ésta es la que tiene la
llave correspondiente o tal vez
deberíamos decir la cerradura
correspondiente para la llave que es
o patógeno entonces este patógeno se
unirá a la célula ve tal vez un virus o
una bacteria y la célula se activará
aunque como veremos en este vídeo la
activación no siempre sucede de hecho
casi nunca sucede sólo con esto pero
sabemos que si se activan entonces se
transforma en células de memoria que
básicamente son múltiples versiones de
estas células original es decir tenemos
múltiples versiones de ella porque estas
van a reconocer el virus si en el futuro
tenemos a este virus entonces estas
múltiples versiones las células vez de
memoria estarán allí para participar en
esta interacción es decir en el futuro
esta interacción va a ser más probable
porque tenemos muchas más de esta
variedad de células b por otra parte
tenemos las células efectoras o
plasmáticas
una vez que estas células se activan
proliferan continúa divirtiéndose y
clonados en las células de memoria se
quedarán a la espera de ser activadas en
el futuro y voy a dibujar uno de estos
anticuerpos que están unidos a la
membrana pero en realidad hay 10.000 de
ellos es más vamos a dibujar algunos más
las células de memoria van a deambular
por allí pero ahora hay más de ellas así
que si en el futuro tenemos este virus
de nuevo esta interacción sucederá más
rápido y por lo tanto se activará
también más rápido mientras que las
células efectoras o plasmáticas se
convierten en fábricas de anticuerpos
puedes decir ahora que estoy activada
voy a producir muchas más versiones de
este anticuerpo exacto así que estas
versiones salen para deshabilitar o
etiquetar antígenos pero
no cualquier antígeno sino este antígeno
que tenemos aquí sabemos también que las
células se convierten en células
presentadoras de antígeno entonces tan
pronto reconoce al antígeno interactúa
con él uniendo la parte variable del
anticuerpo asociado a la membrana y lo
en dos cita lo atrae hacia el la
membrana lo facilitan por lo que
simplemente lo jala lo corta y después
presenta una parte de este anticuerpo en
una molécula cmt2 y esto es lo que vimos
en el último vídeo en este vídeo vamos a
hablar de por qué incluso nosotros
tenemos estas moléculas c m h 2 es decir
para que presentamos estos antígenos así
que empecemos hablando de la inmunidad
celular pero más que hablar de la
inmunidad celular en general hablaremos
de las células t
las células t se llaman así debido a que
maduran en el timo y existen dos tipos
de células t y tal vez es un poco
confuso porque tenemos las células ver y
las células stem pero hay dos tipos de
células t
tenemos las células o linfocitos t
colaboradores cuya anotación es t
subíndice h por bueno la palabra en
inglés helper y por otra parte tenemos a
los linfocitos o células citotóxicas que
son células stem que matan otras células
cuya anotación este subíndice ahora sólo
para que tengamos una gran impresión
general de quién hace que vamos a
mencionar que las células ven cuando
están activadas generan anticuerpos este
es el mejor resumen de lo que hacen las
células vez generan anticuerpos los
cuales se unen a los virus bacterias y
otros tipos de patógenos y los
inhabilitan
ya sea que los etiqueten para que los
macrófagos puedan comérselos o pueden
descomponer a los patógenos con todos
los anticuerpos en la superficie o
agruparlos para que los macrófagos los
tomen de manera más sencilla pero esto
es solo efectivo para cosas que estén
deambulando por allí los anticuerpos que
flotan libremente son solo efectivos
para las cosas que flotan por allí sin
embargo las células citotóxicas de las
que hablaremos con mayor detalle en
vídeos futuros atacan células que se han
infiltrado así que esta ataca y mata a
las células infiltradas cuando decimos
infiltradas hablamos de células
controladas por virus o bacterias y
cuando decimos infiltradas
no hablamos necesariamente de alguna
célula del exterior podrían ser células
cancerosas que muestran comportamientos
anormales de alguna forma por lo que las
células t citotóxicas intentarán
matarlas
recuerdan estos tres tipos de células
son linfocitos todo de lo que hemos
hablado son leucocitos es decir glóbulos
blancos y los linfocitos son un
subconjunto de ellos y se llaman así
porque empiezan su desarrollo en la
médula ósea así que estos dos en
realidad hacen cosas importantes este
linfocito genera anticuerpos para unirse
a los patógenos que flotan por allí
mientras que este linfocito ataca
directamente a las células que están
dañadas de alguna forma ya sea que estén
infiltradas sean anormales cancerosas o
lo que sea y haremos un vídeo entero de
todo esto pero todo esto nos deja con
una pregunta bastante obvia qué hacen
estos linfocitos que es lo que hace la
célula t colaboradora si ella no
interfiere directamente con los
patógenos o en la producción de cosas
que interactúan con los patógenos o si
ellas no atacan directamente a las
células y la respuesta es que las
células de colaboradoras son una clase
de alarma del sistema inmunitario de
cierta forma es casi lo más importante
en el último vídeo hablamos de las
células presentadoras de antígeno por
ejemplo un macrófago o las células
dentríticas que toman al patógeno lo
descomponen y lo presentan en su
superficie como proteínas o complejos
cm2 lo mismo hacen las células ven pero
estas son más específicas ahora una vez
que se presenta algo el linfocito t
colaborador entra en escena
vamos a dibujar una célula dendrítica y
la dibujaremos a propósito las células
dentríticas son las mejores
células para activar células t
colaboradoras entonces tenemos esta
célula dendrítica se llama dendrítica
porque parece que tiene de entradas y
esta célula es un favorcito es decir
consume algún tipo de bacteria o virus
lo descompone y después presenta parte
del cuerpo de ese virus en el complejo
cmt2 es parecido a decir oye encuentre a
esta cosa sospechosa alrededor de los
tejidos del cuerpo tal vez alguien
debería dar alarma tal vez esto es parte
de una cosa más grande y debería
activarse algún tipo de alarma y es
justo lo que hacen las células t
colaboradoras pensemos que este
linfocito se presenta y dice encontré
esta cosa sospechosa que aniquilen y
aquí hay parte de ella entonces la
célula te colaboradora tiene un receptor
vamos a dibujarla esta es la célula t
colaboradora y tiene ciertos tipos de
receptores para esta célula t los cuales
se van a unir de esta manera tenemos una
proteína y tal como los anticuerpos
asociados a la membrana en las células
ven donde casi cada célula bebé tiene
una versión distinta es decir una
terminación variable diferente esto se
repite para las células t colaboradoras
de igual manera que las células ven
estas tienen alguna variación en donde
se unen así que esta célula t
colaboradora de aquí va a tener una
variable distinta a otras por ejemplo
podemos tener otra célula t colaboradora
que también tiene un cierto receptor
pero la parte variable de ese receptor
es diferente a la parte variable de este
otro receptor por lo tanto esta célula t
colaboradora
no se va a unir al complejo de m2 de
esta célula dendrítica solo esta pueden
y el mecanismo de cómo tenemos estas
variaciones es muy similar al mecanismo
de cómo obtenemos las variaciones en los
anticuerpos de las células b durante
este desarrollo de las células t
colaboradoras en un punto los genes que
codifican para esta parte del receptor
son mezclados y son mezclados
intencionalmente para que cada célula te
tenga una combinación específica para un
complejo cmt2 y para cierto polipéptido
para cierta parte de un virus así que
solo este tipo va a activarse no este
otro es por esto que llamamos al sistema
inmunitario específico ahora qué es lo
que hace la célula t colaboradora en
este punto
en este punto dice oye yo soy la única
célula t colaboradora que se puede unir
a esta dentríticas a este antígeno que
presenta y así puedo activar me y no voy
a entrar en detalles pero en general las
células dentríticas son las mejores para
activar a las células de colaboradoras
en especial la célula de colaboradora
virgen o ingenua les llamamos células ve
vírgenes o células de colaboradoras
vírgenes a las células que no son de
memoria ni células efectoras ni han sido
activadas en el caso de células b no han
sido activadas por la unión de algo a su
anticuerpo asociado a la membrana o en
el caso de las células de colaboradoras
nada se ha unido a ellas
entonces si esta célula está cam es
virgen y finalmente tiene una reacción
con esta célula presentadora de antígeno
entonces deja de ser virgen y se
convierte en una célula activada y
cuando se activa dos cosas pasan
de igual manera que las células empieza
a proliferar varias veces creando muchas
muchas muchas copias de sí misma y un
subconjunto de estas copias se
diferencia en células t colaboradoras
efectoras efector significa que hacen
algo ahora hacen algo en lugar de
guardar la memoria y otro subconjunto de
ellas se convierte en células t
colaboradoras de memoria después de
activarse ahora las células t de memoria
son parecidas a las células de memoria
ya que si tienes muchas copias de estas
tal vez en 10 años si vuelve a suceder
algo como esto es más probable que esta
interacción se de estas células tienen
el mismo receptor temp que la célula que
les dio origen y esta otra también las
células t de memoria o las células de
memoria viven más ellas no se matan a sí
mismas
así que viven por años entonces tal vez
diez años después si algo como esto se
presenta tendremos más de estas células
que se encontrarán con esta otra célula
para encender la alarma ya que estas
copias tendrán la misma cadena entonces
podemos decir bien tenemos estas células
de memoria que se van a quedar y que
pueden activarse en el futuro pero
todavía no respondemos la pregunta de
qué hacen las células de efectoras bueno
lo que hacen las células de efectoras es
encender la alarma vamos a dibujarla
esta es una célula de efecto ahora que
ha sido activada y recuerda esta es una
célula muy particular esta versión de
células t cuando es activada produce
varias copias de sí misma ya que dicen
oye respondo a sólo un cierto tipo de
patógeno en particular
esta es una célula t colaboradora
efectora y lo que hace es empezar a
producir estas moléculas llamadas y
toxinas empieza a producir citocinas y
hay muchos tipos distintos de citocinas
que no entraré en mucho detalle pero lo
que hace la citosina es realmente
encender la alarma ya que si tenemos
otras células linfáticas activadas u
otras células inmunitarias activadas
entonces cuando las citocinas entran a
esas células recordemos las citocinas
son simplemente proteínas o polipéptidos
y cuando entran a esas células las hace
ponerse en marcha entonces las hace
multiplicarse más seguido o las hace más
activas en sus responsabilidades inmunes
entonces lo que hacen estas citoquinas
que podemos ver como alarmas químicas o
alarmas peptídicas químicas es poner en
marcha actos
esta es una de las responsabilidades
centrales y las citocinas le tiran a las
células t citotóxicas que se pongan en
marcha y también les dirá a las células
ven que se sigan proliferando así que
cuando una célula ve activada obtiene
algo de estas y tocina de una célula
colaboradora t local ésta le dirá am hoy
en divide más seguido divide t más
seguido esto sucederá sólo en el caso de
que esta célula esté activada y ya
veremos el por qué tiene que ser este el
caso ya que no queremos que se activen
todas las células b
cuando hablamos de células b dijimos ok
tenemos una célula be y aquí tenemos los
anticuerpos asociados a la membrana que
recordemos son una versión particular ya
que tienen por aquí
esta cadena particular variable y esta
célula se une a un patógeno tal vez sea
un virus
y hasta ahora habíamos mencionado que
esta célula está activada una vez que se
une al patógeno lo ingiere toma parte de
él lo corta y pone parte de él en la
molécula cnh 2 y como hemos dicho ya que
está activada va a proliferar y se va a
diferenciar en células de memoria y en
células efectoras pero esto no es del
todo cierto la primera etapa sucede este
patógeno se une esta célula tiene que
ser específica para ese virus descompone
el virus pone partes del virus en su
superficie y presenta partes del
antígeno pero en muchos casos esta
célula ve todavía no se activa puedes
ver esto como entrar en un estado de
reposo
lista para activarse pero todavía no
prolifera ni se va a diferenciar en
células efectoras o de memoria para que
eso suceda se requiere una célula t
colaboradora activada que sea específica
para este mismo virus así que podemos
imaginar que en algún lugar de esta
célula este virus ha sido ingerido por
la célula dendrítica así que vamos a
dibujarla tenemos la misma especie de
virus ingerido por la célula dendrítica
esta célula lo ingiere lo descompone y
presenta el antígeno justo aquí entonces
esto se activa a una célula t en
específico vamos a dibujarla tenemos una
célula t que llega y se encuentra con la
célula dendrítica recordemos no
cualquier célula t sino la célula t con
la parte variable adecuada ahora
pensemos que ocurre la parte variable de
esta célula temp
se conecta con esta parte del virus y
con el cnh 2 pero realmente reacciona al
mismo virus tal vez sea una parte
distinta esta pequeña parte que se cortó
de una parte interna del virus mientras
que el epítome de la célula ve este en
algún lugar fuera del virus pero ambas
células son específicas para el mismo
virus ahora cuando esta célula t se
activa empieza a producir células
efectoras y de memoria que son
descendientes de ella y uno de esos
efectores que es específico a este virus
se necesita unir a estas células así que
esta célula hace este camino y llega
hasta acá y como es específica también a
ese mismo virus entonces este sitio de
unión es el mismo que este otro es decir
esta combinación de antígeno con cm2
entonces cuando se unen de esta forma y
recordemos este sitio de unión es igual
que este otro y solo se une a esta
combinación de aquí entonces esta unión
es lo que activa a las células
la activación depende de ti en la
mayoría de los casos a veces solo se
necesita esta primera etapa pero de
manera general se necesita la primera
etapa y también se necesita una célula t
que venga a activar a las células y sólo
así la célula desactivará proliferarán
se va a dividir se va a diferenciar y
producirán células efectoras que
producirán anticuerpos pero una pregunta
natural es por qué tenemos este sistema
doble y al menos mi opinión es que
tenemos un mecanismo a prueba de fallos
ya que si cada vez que un virus llega y
ataca esta célula ve y ésta empieza a
producir anticuerpos como local entonces
existe una probabilidad de que después
de este desarrollo
estos genes que producen estas cadenas
se vuelvan específicas pero no para
patógenos extraños sino para moléculas
que se producen en el cuerpo de manera
natural es decir tendríamos una mutación
aleatoria pero si esta célula empieza
alocarse por ello estos anticuerpos
empezarían a atacar moléculas que se
encuentran de manera natural en el
cuerpo y eso nos lastimaría esta es la
razón del por qué ocurren enfermedades
autoinmunes ocurren cuando nuestras
células inmunes se activan por sí solas
pero si tenemos este sistema doble donde
necesitamos que esto suceda y que esto
otro suceda entonces la probabilidad de
que ambos tipos de células después de
terminar su desarrollo se vuelvan
específicas para cierta proteína oa
ciertas células oa cierta molecular del
propio cuerpo es muy poco probable
así que esto inhibe a esta célula vez de
volverse loca incluso si tienes cierto
tipo de mutación de cualquier manera
espero que esto te ayude a explicar un
poco lo que hacen las células t pero
seguiremos hablando poco a poco de ello
ya que esto es un poco confuso en el
siguiente vídeo hablaremos de las
células t citotóxicas